[Music]
music video is grabbing the internet's
attention in a whole new way as reports
claim the singer allegedly discovered
her ex Gerard PK was cheating on her
thanks to a way for it a jar of jam it's
been quite a journey yeah according to
reports the singer discovered the
retired Soccer Star whom she split from
last year was unfaithful after she
noticed her Jam Supply had gone down
while she went on a trip and allegedly
Shakira is the only person in her family
who likes the sweet sauce which leads to
speculation about who is eating it all
this brings us back to the Tay felicito
video featuring Rao Alejandro
[Music]
yep Shaq finds Rao's head in the fridge
the same spot she allegedly found the
diminished Jam there's a moment in the
video where you go to the fridge and
you're not going to the fridge for milk
tell me about that what's going on to
find out the truth so I go to the
refrigerator and when I find rawatan
under his head which is pretty scary I
guess that it happens to all of us once
in a while you know
us women
that you think that you're in a real
relationship and it's not as real as it
seems ET has reached out to Shakira for
common meanwhile the Colombian Stars
dropping new music following her split
[Music]
in the Grammy Winner's first single of
the Year business rap music session
number 53 she seemingly Shades her
former
[Music]
bows
and Shake even takes aim at Gerard's new
girlfriend Clara chiamarti who's 23
singing the lines I wish you the best
with my supposed replacement I don't
even know what happened to you you are
so strange that I can't even distinguish
you I'm worth two of 22 year old you
traded a Ferrari for a twingo you traded
a Rolex for a Casio and that diss track
is a big hit on social media and the
Billboard charts less than two days
after its release it's also amassed over
152 million views on YouTube
[Music]
foreign